[Musique]
je peux le dire d'ici vous êtes tous des
gens bien évidemment il ya les 3%
délinquants j'envoie de la une la à la
barre en les autres désolé et en même
temps c'est pas ce qui nous intéresse ce
qui nous intéresse c'est vous autres les
gens bien et les gens bien parfois font
des choses mal souvent bon il a l'air un
peu austère et ça peu folle tibet mais
il a eu une bande d'amis et ils ont eu
un chef-d'oeuvre mais ce sont des
vient alors la science a été interloquée
la science s'est demandé pourquoi des
gens bien pouvait faire des horreurs je
vais vous parler david roch qui a réuni
des chercheurs dans un ensemble qu'ils
appellent leur leadership institute
les gens qui font de la recherche en
neurosciences qui a un objet en
leadership ou en management et david est
formel nous sommes
la raison c'est en nous c'est dans notre
adn c'est dans notre cerveau nous avons
un cerveau qui fait la différence entre
la douleur de cet enfant et la douleur
cet homme on ressent des choses où on en
ressent pas et ça vient probablement de
cette époque
alors c'est une mauvaise représentation
on était plutôt comme ça et on vivait en
clans d'une cinquantaine de personnes et
l'appartenance à ce clan était la
condition de notre survie
ce n'était pas un choix c'est une
nécessité et on a gardé
évidemment les attitudes nécessaires à
cette époque je dis évidemment parce que
l'adn mais très longtemps a changé l'adn
pour vous donner un exemple nous
consommons tous du lait depuis 7000 ans
la moitié de la population ne le digère
pas cette milan une 2010 pour l'adn sur
un élément essentiel de notre
alimentation est essentielle courant
notre adn
bush très lentement
le shass
cueilleurs avait besoin d'appartenir au
groupe
son adn a évoulé pour ça en revanche un
individu qui se pointe sur le territoire
du chasseur cueilleur qu'il ne parle pas
le même langage qui veut éventuellement
voler son silex le gisement de silex
c'était le pétrole d'aujourd'hui ça
s'appelle un gibier et votre cerveau va
vous permettre de le frapper de le
blesser de le tuer de l'ouvrir de l'idée
de le manger le cerveau vous permet ça
pour survivre ça c'est
16 les chercheurs d'art
on cherchait à vérifier l'hypothèse ils
ont demandé à des élèves d'apprendre
l'allemand avec cette jeune femme avec
ce monsieur
je vais vous surprendre
ce monsieur parle très bien l'allemand
les étudiants de ce monsieur ne parlait
pas bien allemand leur cerveau avait mis
en place un véritable voile qui empêche
le passage de toute information
si on commence à comprendre ce monsieur
comment ce qu'on va pouvoir le tuer
alors voilà ce que nous faisons nous
mettons les gens qui ne nous plaisent
pas dans la boîte à monstres et nous le
faisons constamment et sans même nous en
apercevoir
je suis venu en scooter une voiture a
manqué de me renverser
vous pensez bien on va finir conducteur
et en même temps j'imagine que j'ai su
passer dans sa boîte amont sera lui
aussi et qu'il m'a souhaité d'aller dans
un mur pour m'apprendre la vie alors ce
que je vous propose c'est de réduire la
taille de cette boîte à monstres d'en
réduire l' usage d'en prendre conscience
déjà car le plus grand sera cette boîte
à monstre le plus vous risquez de
devenir vous même des monstres le plus
réduit sera cette boîte à mons et le
mieux nous pourrons vivre ensemble
demain
[Applaudissements]